pretty burns and not the good way not in
the field of bird way it's day two of
the DNC last night Bernie Sanders
addressed arena and reporters to fall in
line with the party ancillary clearance
a lot of an elegant here aren't having
it burned everybody in that stadium that
supported Bernie that voted form that
donated knocked on doors were actually
pretty pissed they've talked a lot about
progressive platforms the most
progressive but it's not progressive
enough it also did not satisfy black
lives matter it's lacking and it was a
language supporting LGBTQI age really
unfair really undemocratic and it's hard
to not be mad because they don't even
publicly acknowledge it this election to
me the low point in America for the
Christian super hang really yes they are
disappointed
the reincarnation is gone and the reason
you're saying you don't have your voice
is too much yelling yesterday when you
when she becomes official nominee are
you gonna move
what